[Applaudissements]
elles sont jeunes moins jeunes viennent
d'horizons différents mais elles ont
toutes la même passion pour les styles
vestimentaires des années 50 60 aux
etats unis
pour elle le corps de la femme est plus
beau aussi j'avais rien à prouver mais
j'avais envie de te faire voir aux
femmes que assumer ses formes c'est
important pour un bien-être personnel
et puis moi j'avais envie de voir des
petites étoiles dans les yeux de ma
fille l'esprit vintage
c'était une période de vie où les gens
avaient certes des soucis mais il y
avait toujours l'esprit on pouvait
s'amuser sortir cette élection à miss
pin up c'est d'abord pour ses dix femmes
un moment de plaisir et les amis ne sont
jamais loin pour soutenir
on est là pour supporter carroll qui
vient de châteauroux la voilà on
représente la région forte mais des amis
de la famille oui on est tous une vente
de biker de châteauroux et des
inventeurs et puis après le défilé sur
scène c'est le défilé dans les allées du
salon les visiteurs sont forcément
complice en super jolie super féminine
élégante
voilà on aurait presque envie de leur
ressembler c'est un look
je n'arriverai pas à mettre
quotidiennement mais ça leur va très
bien pour julie c'était la première
participation à un concours elle a été
poussée par son mari et l'habiller comme
ça depuis des années tous les jours en
fait pour nous c'est normal c'est son
style c'est pas juste un costume pour un
salon et les voulait pas s'inscrire
c'est
les amis la famille on n'est pas passés
maintenant quoi ils avancent à mina 18
ans pour elle aussi
c'était son premier concours et elle est
peut-être un peu impressionnés nous
avons du coup c'est un peu stressant de
voir des personnes en bas beaucoup plus
âgée que moi elle avait l'air d'être
plus à l'aise en fait alors sentir
oui les organisateurs attendent et 4000
visiteurs sur ces deux jours ils
prévoient donc d'organiser le deuxième
salon vintage l'année prochaine toujours
agir